So there's now a discussion happening about
how soon Joe Biden and Democrats should wait
for Republicans to negotiate on the covid
relief bill before just going forward and
passing it without Republican support via
budget reconciliation if Democrats have the
votes in the Senate.
Now, there are people criticizing Joe Biden.
Why is Joe Biden meeting with Republicans
about the covid bill?
Why is Joe Biden inviting 10 Democrats, 10
Republican senators to meet as he did last
night?
When these people are clearly bad faith actors,
there's not going to be unity.
There's not going to be negotiation.
That gets us anything close to what Joe Biden
wants, which is a one point nine trillion
dollar package.
And I basically agree with all of that other
than to say the meeting is fine.
Let's just understand that after the meeting,
Republicans, as we've already seen them do
this morning, are going to insist that they
want some pathetic 600 billion dollar stimulus
bill, these same senators who now are going
back to the tired old tropes of Republicans,
we can't afford it, but where's the money
going to come from?
But inflation.
But the debt, but the deficit.
People who said nothing as Trump exploded
the deficit despite claiming he would pay
off the entire national debt during his first
term, these same Republican senators gleefully,
happily voted for 740 billion dollars for
the military budget just recently.
So they are hypocrites.
They are exactly who we believed them to be.
They are going to obstruct and get in the
way and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Joe Biden's proposal is for one point nine
trillion dollars.
These Republicans want 618 billion.
And they met yesterday with Joe Biden.
So I think that the meeting with them is fine
as long as Joe Biden and Democrats are ready
to say, listen.
Remember, they promised 2000 dollar checks
would go out right away.
It's February now, right away we could debate
what right away means and government speak.
But Joe Biden definitely made us think, John
USCIRF definitely made us think that the checks
were going out quickly.
It's been a couple of weeks almost now.
OK, so it's time to do it, have the meeting
with the Republicans, but understand that
Republicans are going to make all sorts of
demands.
They are going to demand capitulation to their
ideology, to their platform.
They will weaken the bill.
They will weaken the impact of the bill.
And ultimately, even if you come up with something
that's between 600 billion and one point nine
trillion, they'll probably still refuse to
vote for it anyway.
OK, these are not good faith actors.
So don't be mad that Joe Biden is meeting
with Republicans.
I'm fine with it.
It's fine that he's doing it.
He claimed he wants bipartisanship and unity
and all this stuff.
That's fine.
They were able to propose their six hundred
billion dollar package and they are likely
to vote against whatever compromise Democrats
end up proposing.
So my view is give them a meeting and then
pass one point nine trillion without a single
Republican, if that's what they want to do.
Now, you need Jim, if you don't get a single
Republican, you need Joe Manchin to vote.
And we need to be sure that Joe Manchin is
going to vote for it.
Republicans will shriek.
They will demand that they be met halfway.
They will say, what about unity?
What about bipartisanship, blah, blah, blah.
But when it's Democrats asking Republicans
to meet them halfway, when Trump is in power,
remember what Republicans said?
Well, elections have consequences.
We're not going to just because you guys want
this different thing.
Trump won and we control this and we control
that.
So Democrats should have a spine and be ready
because for an issue to have a compromise,
both sides have to concede things to make
that work.
The Republican Party is not offering to concede
anything.
The Democratic proposal is one point nine
trillion and it's popular with the American
people.
Republicans are just saying no.
Is the concession that they will grant any
money because remember, many Republican voters
want the stimulus package as well.
This is not a stimulus package that is only
popular with Democratic voters.
Republicans are not conceding anything.
They are negotiating when they don't actually
have leverage if Joe Biden and Democrats are
actually ready and willing to pass this without
a single Republican vote.
So my suggestion is ignore the bad faith whining
of Republicans.
Democrats are passing popular bills that 60,
70, 80 percent of Americans support.
The executive order on asking from Joe Biden.
And you can't you know, we talk about we don't
want to stoop to their level.
We don't want to do what they do.
Listen, we're not obstructing anything.
Joe Biden one Democrats control the House.
Democrats took the Senate voters, including
independents, Democrats, but also Republicans
want the stimulus.
So just pass it.
You gave them their meeting.
It's time to pass it.
You promised you would do it.
And I hope that they actually do.
This could be the first major success of the
Biden administration.
And it will show that it's Joe Biden who will
set the agenda and Democrats, not Mitch McConnell,
or this will be the first major failure for
Joe Biden.
And it will be a big failure.
When you say if I win and OSF and Warnaco
in 2000, checks are going out right away and
we get into February 10th, mid-February, late
February, and you still don't have anything
passed or you end up passing something that's
pathetic and paltry.
That's not going to look good.
So it's time to get it together.
Let's, as we like to say, put on our big boy
pants and get this thing done.
These people, these Republicans are not your
friends.
They're not going to help you.
They're not looking to compromise.
They're looking to get in your way.
You've got to go round them on this important
issue.